[Applaudissements]
Ne m'emmène pas
[Musique]
pas il faut oublier
tout à tous
oublier qui s'enfuit
laissez les temps de malentendus et
temps
commentaire savoir perdu
[Musique]
oublier ces heures qui tu es parfois a
cou
de
pourquoi le cur du
Bonheur Ne me quitte
pas ne me quitte
passer
quoi
Moi je t'offrirai
de perles de
pluie venue de pays o IL Ne pleut pas Je
creuser la terre jusqu'après ma mort
pour couvrir ton corps dans et de lumi Je
ferai un domaine o l'amour sera roi oou
l'amour sera loi ou tu seras
je quitte
[Musique]
enlève-moi
passe-moi décoller
pas moi
quitter
[Musique]
pas ne me quitte
pas Je t'invite
des mots
Je pensais que tu comprendrais
Je te
parlerai de ces amants Qui ont
Vu deux fois leur curs'
braser Je te raconterai l'histoire de ce
roi
mort de n'avoir
pas eu te
[Musique]
rencontrer Ne quitte
pas ne me quitte
pas Ne quitte pas
je
quitte On A
Tu rejaillir souvent le feu de l'anticien
volcan qu'on croyait trop vieux IL est
para est-il des terres brulées donnant
Plus de ble qu'un meilleur Avril et
qu'on vient le soir pour qu'un ciel
flamb bois le Rouge et le noir Ne
[Musique]
s'épiler Je Ne vais Plus
Speaking
Heh je cache
tu regardes
danseur
[Musique]
sourir t'écouter
chanter puis rire laisse-moi
devenir
l'ombre de ton ombre
le nom de ta Main
l'ombre d'une tonne de plus chien ne me quitte
passer
Ne m'emmène pas
pas ne me quitte
pas ne quitte
passer